hey everyone how's it going today I just
landed in Orlando for the Grace Hopper
celebration for those of you who don't
know the Grace Hopper celebration is an
annual conference for women in
technology where thousands of women get
together and it's a three-day conference
where we talk about technology and kind
of like what it's like to be a woman in
tech and there's a lot of great talks a
lot of great keynotes got a lot of great
guests also a lot of good networking
events and mixers afterwards I'm really
excited about this is my second Grace
Hopper last year was my first time and
it was so cool just to be in a room with
so many women and technology because I
mean you know they're not that many like
usually it's like me and 10 other dudes
so being like surrounded by so many
women is just like so cool things that
I'm hoping to do here go to a lot of
sessions and go to a lot of toxin luring
just a lot to meet a lot of people a lot
of the people that come to Grace Hopper
tend to be students but they're all so
inspiring they've done so much and
they're just so eager to learn and I get
really energized been meeting a lot of
these people a number of you go to
networking events I'm helping actually
to host one myself with some friends for
an iOS donor but that's happening on
Thursday and other than that just kind
of having fun all right
[Music]
you're a big part of the reason that I
believe that this is
formative moment for women
for men for tech and for our future
[Music]
since I just went to a talk which turned
out to be a workshop and because they
were like eight people working on our
project we just kind of like hung out
and I ended up sitting with a bunch of
students it was really fun we just kind
of talked about stuff but I just feel so
energized I'm just very happy to have
met you all and I'm just buzzing with
all of the enthusiasm you have for
software engineering computer science
[Music]
to be here and I love it
yeah
you want a great supper ready
I'm here interviewing people
I just watched the keynote online Andrew
Cole goldieblox CEO talked Debbie
sterling and her life journey so
incredible I trade up all watching her
talk and I got a lot of like goosebumps
and stuff but I was like wow she's so
cool
and you know doing YouTube stuff is like
reminds me a lot of this stuff
[Music]
silent
thousand person
it's hard to connect to
[Music]
hey y'all it's been about a week since I
got back from Grace Hopper this year's
Grace Hopper was super fun as always and
I left feeling so inspired from all the
talks and all of the people that I got
to meet this time around my favorite
part about tech conferences including
Grace Hopper is that I get to meet all
of these people who share similar
interest as me and I get to learn from
them as well and so if you ever have a
chance to check out the Grace Hopper
celebration or any other tech
communities either online or in real
life I highly recommend it I'm very
intentional about making sure that I go
to conferences like these I think it's
really cool that you get to meet people
who are basically solving the same
problems as you but they're coming from
a very different background and
perspective and I think that's really
cool as I said in my vlog my favorite
part about Grace Hopper is gathering
with so many women and technology and
being able to see all the inspirational
work that they're doing and meeting them
and learning from them so anyways here's
the woman that I got to meet this time
around with a very special guest at the
very end so keep on watching
[Music]
a systems engineer or
my name is Mei Ling masters little
dignity
[Music]
hi I'm Kristina Thai I'm an iOS software
engineer working at Intuit
my name is Kara this other Barbara City
College it's my first time here and I'm
so happy to be here that's so great
hello nice I'm only Kilauea I'm DevOps
rocked it
my research interest on power and energy
- Megan I'm at the third us chief
technology officer and now I have a new
company's bunch of seven at ship seven
coke you know technology is a really
important set of tools and things and I
really encourage you anyone to consider
coming into the tech sector there's lots
of different kinds of jobs some of them
are more artistic or marketing some of
them are coding front-end back-end or
project management sales whatever cuz
there's 600,000 jobs open all over the
country and every different kind of
probably not just tech companies but
medical tummies and retail and
manufacturing Internet of Things and so
it's a lot of opportunity and it's
really fun there's a lot of challenges
with diversity in tech especially in
Silicon Valley but not all the way
across the country and we're also we're
working hard to change that and so we
need you to come
you know hey you thanks so much for
watching if you like this video please
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to my
channel for more videos and if there are
any tech communities that you enjoy
being a part of then let us know in the
comments below
I think it's cool to be able to talk
about these communities so that other
people can join and join in on the fun
thanks as always and hope you have a
great day
[Music]